brought a clip of your wife actually
right I brought it well I I did said
they asked me or your staff said what's
it like like marriage for 40 years how
do you make it interesting I don't know
if I make it interesting as I do
annoying and my wife I'll show you I
brought this clip because she got really
mad at me she did it was her birthday
and I wanted to surprise my wife my wife
loves animals any kind of animal she
does and we we work for preserve and
give some so I an elephant I rented an
elephant I rented an elephant and I had
it brought to the house cuz it's a big I
wanted I love her know what I did I did
go big yeah but I'm not a good planner
and I have severe attention
I didn't invite anybody I didn't cater I
didn't bring even a staff so just like
an elephant showed up well let me show
you the video and then I'm gonna talk
about the trouble so this is my wife's
birthday watch what I did for my wife's
birthday watch this this is my wife's
birthday party that's my wife there's
the elephant and there's my wife I had
nothing so stupid I don't think of this
and also because we care about animals
you can't just bring an animal for an
hour an animal he had to be like out of
the whatever the transport thing for at
least 12 hours yeah so the animal was in
our backyard for 12 hours so wait wait
and and I don't have that kind of
attention and my wife is bored after
half hour so we went in the house but
elephants they like palm trees so the
elephant took out all our palm trees
though elephant took him out and laid
them down and then the element how much
clearer can I make it so and then and
then the elephant needed to be
comfortable so they said I should hose
so I hosed the elephant which made it
muddy and then the elephant they're
heavy the elephant sunk into my lawn and
broke the sprinklers all the sprinklers
wait wait wait
and then we I ordered food not for us
but for the elephant the elephant ate
and then the elephant is very regular
the elephant is very regular oh my god
that's what the guy who came to our
backyard the next day said because there
are piles of elephant dung
there so there was a so the next day the
gardener do we have a gardener gardener
came it comes around the corner
the the yard is these holes that are
four feet deep the sprinklers are broken
five palm trees are laying all over the
place and there's a pile of you can put
a bleep on right there's a pile yes
there's a there's a giant there is no
and the guy walks in and it goes mr.
Mendell what what is this and I go it
was my wife's birthday
I never explained there was forty five
thousand dollars damage the sprinklers
the trees and elephant poo removal is
not a service that is nearby so your
gifts to your wife for her birthday was
just severely pissing her off you know
what I'm consistent I'm fairly
consistent it's not any different on
their birthday than it is each and every
day it's important to me you know what
she loves about me is that I'm here and
she's not she gets a long time without
me I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this